[Music]
the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now or next
our media group
it is no longer a party it's a socialist
party
tonight on politics now switching
parties north las vegas mayor john lee
tells us why he has decided to become a
republican
plus you have a trio of candidates that
really bubbled to the surface
it's a year and a half away but the 2022
governor's race is starting to take
shape we speak with las vegas review
journal
editor steve sibelius about sheriff joe
lombardo throwing his hat into the ring
and from stopping federal agents to
expanding voter access and regulating
home births
we take you through the week at the
legislature
[Music]
from eight news now this is politics now
we thank you very much for joining us
here on politics now i'm john langler
clark county sheriff joe lombardo has
confirmed this week
he is considering running for governor
lombardo told the review journal he is
kicking the tires
on a run although sheriff is a
non-partisan position lombardo
if he does run says he would run as a
republican
sources tell our i-team he is talking
with fellow republicans congressman mark
amaday
former lieutenant governor mark
hutchison about picking
one of those three candidates and then
supporting them we'll get into that a
little bit later on
in our interview with steve sibelius
from the rj north las vegas mayor john
lee announced this week he is switching
parties
he's now a republican i've been thinking
about it for quite a while
as seeing the way the country has been
going watching what's happened in
national news
and also seeing the responses that take
place in
in within our state and when
the socialists took over the democratic
party it was a sign to me that
there is no more democratic party that i
thought i understood 20 25 years
mayer is a nonpartisan office here in
nevada but
lee was registered as a democrat when he
served in the legislature and when he
ran for congress
that socialist takeover he's referring
to that is members of the democratic
socialists of america that won positions
and control essentially
of the state democratic party lee's
current term runs out in 2022
but he did not say if he plans to run
for higher office
i think that sometimes if one person
will stick their head up and say
it's time we can't continue to go down
this path any further
that possibly that changes the decisions
of a lot of other people just to follow
waiting for someone to say which way do
we go i hope a lot of people will pay
attention to this and say
i understand the way to go i would like
people to come with me
because nevada is too dang important for
all of us lee's referring to trying to
get voters to go with him to the
republican party
now we did reach out to the nevada
democrats for a comment on this
we did not get a response so back to
that race for governor it is starting to
shape up for 2022 perhaps john lee will
be involved
it does appear incumbent democrat steve
sisolak will run
again i spoke with las vegas review
journal politics editor steve sibelius
about how those races are shaping up
now point out though this interview
happened before joe lombardo said he was
considering running
you asked about governor on the
democratic side
obviously steve cyslak is the incumbent
and uh
he is uh planning to run for reelection
or at least all indications are at this
point that he's gonna plan to run for
re-election
uh there have been some whispers that
he's he's not going to do it
uh but i happen to think that if that
was the case he probably would have uh
said so maybe if shortly after the
legislative session concludes he'll say
so
if he's not planning to do it but right
now all indications are
that he is going to run so there you
have the the democratic side now on the
republican side
uh there's some there's something
interesting going on that you don't
always see you have
a trio of candidates that really bubble
to the surface
and then those candidates are uh
representative mark amade of the second
district lives up in reno
the the uh former lieutenant governor
mark hutchison uh who is also a former
state senator and clark county sheriff
joe lombardo
they both lived down here in southern
nevada um
and what's what's interesting and and
somewhat unprecedented is that those
three are
talking they're having conversations
behind the scenes
with each other basically on the premise
of look
a a republican primary where we all run
against each other
spend all the money and come out wounded
and poor
is not in the best interest of the party
so we need to agree amongst ourselves
who is the best candidate and then that
person will run
without having to deal with a republican
primary with high
name contenders there's going to be
probably some people who get in
who you've never heard of but just the
top people and so
those three are the names we hear most
often there's some other names besides
those three that you're hearing
might jump in i understand that it's
still a long way away
it is still a long way away and there
are some other names interestingly
enough
dean heller has been mentioned he wanted
to run for governor before but he
deferred to adam laxalt
i think he may regret that decision now
given that laxalt uh performed so poorly
in the general
uh but we still assume regardless of
that performance that adam laxalt will
perform
well in a republican primary so he is
going to be a formidable candidate
regardless of which race he chooses
right now
looks like he's going to run for senate
if he wants to do that
can a moderate republican someone such
as a
mark hutchinson or or a ben kieckefer
win
a republican primary what does the trump
base do
in adam laxalt's case we know what
they'll do they'll turn out and vote for
laxalt no question
but a moderate is that person going to
get support
in a republican primary that's an open
question and that could really affect
some of the
of the candidates here on the democratic
side obviously as you mentioned there's
steve sisalak he's the incumbent he is a
democrat
you mentioned he's in all likelihood
gonna run again but is it possible given
the recent
uh changes with the nevada democratic
party that he could be primaried
it it is possible i have heard more than
once from
more than one person the name marilyn
kirkpatrick
as a potential candidate for uh for
governor she's done a really good job as
chairwoman of the clark county
commission
and and i think she might have
aspirations
to do that um i think that might
be less likely um uh you you mentioned
the democratic party and whether or not
a progressive uh candidate a more
liberal candidate in the mold of bernie
sanders
uh would would challenge steve cyslek
for for governor
i tend to think that that is probably
not likely
that of course steve sibelius political
editor at the las vegas review journal a
familiar face here at 8 news now
we have our entire discussion online we
also talk about the race 4 senate
it's over at 8newsnow.com nevada's
secretary of state's office reports a
slight dip
in active voter registrations from march
there was a decrease of 642 voters
nevada has 1.8 million active registered
voters now
every political party saw a slight
decrease in registration
the only bump in nonpartisan voters that
increased by nearly 5400
now to the legislative session friday
was a key deadline in carson city
bills had to make it out of their first
committee now we're going to go through
a lot of those next week on politics now
but for now
let's look at a few hearings on bills
this week one bill that keeps local law
enforcement from cooperating
with federal immigration officials has
now moved out of committee that happened
this week
this is assembly bill 376. it is
sponsored by democrat assemblywoman
celine
celina torres among other things this
would keep law enforcement from putting
immigration holds on people without a
federal warrant
it would also limit when police could
ask someone their immigration status
nevada's republican party opposes the
measure the republicans say
90 percent of people arrested for being
in the country illegally
had outstanding criminal charges metro
police suspended their coordination
program with ice back in 2019
democrats in carson city hope a proposal
to expand automatic voter registration
might help clean up the voter rolls
assembly bill 432 would allow more
government agencies to help county
clerks
automatically register voters this would
include medicaid
and other state agencies because quite
simply not everybody goes to the dmv
the bill is sponsored by assemblyman
howard watts he says this would help
prevent fraud
first of all i think the rampant voter
fraud is a myth
but this prevents unintentional
registration of people who might not be
eligible to vote
so the safeguards are in place in this
policy
and what we're doing is is building on
those and expanding those
judges have repeatedly thrown out
allegations of voter fraud in nevada
if passed this measure would cost nevada
several million dollars to
update computer systems for automatic
voter registration
the secretary of state's office says
there are concerns about that
installation
the state's health exchange says it
would cost about 6 million dollars to
put this measure into place
close to 10 million dollars for all of
the state agencies combined
lawmakers are also considering whether
there should be licensing and oversight
for midwives and home births here in
nevada
right now only one type of midwife is
regulated those are certified nurse
midwives
that are registered nurses already with
the state however
there is no oversight of traditional
midwives and certified professional
midwives
and many don't have medical training
assembly bill 387
is sponsored by democrat assemblywoman
danielle monroe moreno
it would create oversight of this
practice opponents of the measure say
any regulation would take away a woman's
choice
about where she can give birth and who
can care for her the first hearing was
on monday
licensure is a key to providing safe
care for nevadans
that is consistent with the scope of
practice defined by the profession
we cannot support a bill that will
decrease the middle free labor workforce
in nevada
negatively impact future workforce
development detract from nevada's
historical support of apprenticeship
trades
there is also a senate bill under
consideration on this
you can check out the i-team's full
reports on the issue at 8newsnow.com
coming up next on politics now expanding
voting access
or not coming up we're going to hear
from democratic senator jackie rosen
and republican leader mitch mcconnell on
some measures being considered
side choices from enfoyo loco
welcome back to politics now
nye county plans to be the first part of
nevada to lift
a mask mandate commissioners are also
expecting to go to 100 percent capacity
in businesses
so right now the state mass mandate is
still in effect
control of coronavirus plans and
restrictions that gets turned over to
the counties
statewide may 1st so on that day
nyah county plans to make those changes
commissioners voted this week
they on this measure they say the
county's infection rate is between 5
and 7 percent and the cases have
remained flat but they're still
encouraging people to wear masks the
state board will review and approve the
reopening plan later this month
the race for clark county commission
district c it is still surprisingly
unsettled at least
according to a republican candidate and
las vegas city councilman stavros
anthony
his lawyers brought a lawsuit over the
election before the state supreme court
oral arguments began this week you'll
remember anthony lost the district c
county commission race in november to
democrat ross miller
clark county commissioners first
suggested they would hold a special
election but then they
backed down from that the courts
expected to take several months before
issuing a ruling battles over new voting
rules in georgia and other states has
put congressional legislation at the
forefront
democrats are pushing h.r 1 which
they've dubbed
the for the people act democrats say it
would expand voter access
president joe biden is pushing his party
to get it to his desk
the i-team's david charns asked nevada
senator jackie rosen if she supports the
bill
before the people act we have you know
legislation here in nevada to expand
voting um we also have legislation that
is likely not going to pass because it
doesn't have the numbers to restrict
voting and then
nationally we have the for the people
act to you know
solidify some of voting rights what's
your stance on that right now
my stance is this is that it is a
bedrock of our democracy
that every vote counts that we tell
everyone your voice is your
vote and so i want to be sure that
everyone has
equal access to the ballot box all
across america
this is not a democratic republican
issue this
is an american issue the world is
watching
and so there's been no evidence of voter
fraud we need to be
sure that we have equitable access to
the ballot box
everywhere so everyone who's eligible to
vote
has the right to make their voice heard
and the world is watching how we do that
is there anything in the bill that you
wouldn't support right now
or you i mean i know it's early but is
there something in it that you'd like to
see or you haven't seen
well you know what they're still working
on all the final languages between the
house and the senate version so we'll
we'll see what that actually comes down
to as people begin to discuss it
nevada's other democratic senator
catherine cortez masto also supports the
for the people act
republicans oppose the bill senate
minority leader mitch mcconnell laid out
why on march 25th it would forcibly
rewrite every state's election laws in
ways that defy common sense
and are deeply unpopular with american
voters
it would mandate nearly unrestricted
same-day registration
it would mandate big loopholes that
would render voter id
almost meaningless it would make every
state legalize ballot harvesting where
paid operatives can turn up carrying big
piles of ballots with other people's
names on them
zero chain of custody
democrats want to hide behind the mantle
of voting rights what they're really
proposing is less security
less integrity and a grab bag of changes
that are deeply
deeply unpopular just look at the other
changes with zero relationship to voting
rights that democrats want to smuggle in
behind that smoke screen this bill would
take the federal election commission
from an evenly split bipartisan panel
to a partisan body so that democrats
could rule unilaterally
so far a vote on h.r 1 has not been
scheduled on capitol hill
coming up next on politics now we're
going to check in with our washington
d.c bureau
president joe biden announces a set of
executive actions to curb
gun violence and basel john reporting in
washington we have the latest
on the announcement as the weather warms
up more americans want to travel and
gather
but will a vaccine passport be necessary
i'll have the latest
visit redcrossblood.org for more
information
you're watching politics now
this week president joe biden announced
a set of executive actions to curb gun
violence here in the u.s
washington dc correspondent basil john
reports on this latest announcement
gun violence in this country is an
epidemic
thursday president joe biden issued new
executive actions he says will improve
gun safety
we have an opportunity to fulfill the
first responsibility of government
to keep our people safe president
biden's actions
will create tighter regulations around
guns assembled from kits
and pistols with a stabilizing brace as
well as direct the justice department
to publish red flag legislation that can
be adapted by states
just like with background checks the
vast majority of the americans
support these extreme risk protection
order laws
and it's time to put these laws on the
books and protect even more people
but republicans say this is not the
right way for the president to tackle
gun violence
he's not holding people accountable for
their actions
he's holding innocent people accountable
for the actions of people who are
violent pennsylvania republican
congressman fred keller says the
violence doesn't come from the guns
but from bad individuals you're not
going to solve that problem
until you get to the root cause and stop
talking about the instrument somebody
uses
and talk about what causes that behavior
keller says the issue
should be left up to congress but the
president says curbing gun violence
requires taking action whether congress
acts or not
i'm going to use all the resources in my
disposal as president to keep the
american people safe
reporting in washington i'm basil john
bills with similar regulations are being
considered at the legislative session
here in nevada
assembly bill 286 bans those home
assembled firearms kits the ghost
guns we just heard about it's the second
most commented bill
so far more than 2 800 comments in fact
2400 against it
400 for it nevada also previously passed
a law allowing family members
household members and police to get a
court order seizing someone's gun for up
to a year
countries are beginning to implement
vaccine passports both for their own
citizens and for tourists from other
countries
the question is will america be next
some private industries are already
moving in that direction
the travel industry supports the idea
but governors in some red states are
saying no
most people want to travel and they
don't care if they have to show one more
id it's completely unacceptable for
either the government or the private
sector to impose upon you
uh the requirement that you show proof
of vaccine
plenty to talk about from washington dc
that's why we have alexander limon there
with
some of the headlines right now let's
start talking with vaccine passports
some areas have already implemented them
new york city most notably
what is the latest guidance from the
bide administration on putting these in
place
well we've heard from the white house a
couple times now on this issue and
they've been pretty consistent and
adamant as well in saying that it will
not be the federal government that
implements any type of mandate requiring
a vaccine passport or requiring
vaccination in general for people
to do different types of public
activities but they also say they do
recognize like you mentioned that the
private sector
maybe even states or cities may
implement
some sort of vaccine requirement or
vaccine passport requirement
in order to allow people to travel or to
attend really big
public events like sporting events and
so because they recognize it's
likely gonna happen in one form or
another the white house does say they
will help
to develop a system that they say will
hopefully be
fair and accessible to everyone and also
safe to make sure you know that people's
personal safety information isn't being
jeopardized
to hackers or not at risk to be leaked
out to the public
in some places across the country
they're trying to mandate that you can't
have these vaccine passports what's
happening in some of the states across
the country
well in some states we're seeing
governors sign executive orders or new
laws that say
that any state agencies or tax funded
agencies cannot require
any type of vaccine passport or
vaccination proof
but in one state in florida the governor
there has actually gone a step further
and
is requiring that even private
businesses
not be allowed to ask people to require
proof of vaccine
and that's going to be a little tricky
it'll be interesting to see whether or
not governor desantis can move forward
with that
because for example there's a lot of
international travel that happens in and
out of florida
whether it be by air or cruise ships
that go to places that are now starting
to require that tourists
have vaccine passports places like
iceland and greece
for example and that was alex limon from
washington dc
more politics now after
big o tires the team you trust
you're watching politics now
nevada's congressional delegation has
been in southern nevada this week
pitching the american rescue plan
on thursday a group of democrats
gathered up in north las vegas at a food
bank there
senators jackie rosen catherine cortez
masto
congresswoman susie lee and dina titus
and congressman stephen horsford were
all there
taking part in the food bank
more videos are out from the government
investigation into
unidentified flying objects this was
revealed by
our own george knapp this week it shows
a group of flying
pyramids floating above a navy warship
the video clip is part of a briefing
prepared by the pentagon's
u-app task force which is working on a
comprehensive report
for congress about the ufo mystery if
you would like to learn more about this
and the pentagon's task force just head
over to mysterywire.com
you can check out the story there and a
whole lot more about
ufos and flying pyramids thank you very
much for watching politics now this week
you can stay up to date online of course
at 8newsnow.com
we're back with you next saturday with
the latest from carson city in
washington d.c
take care
you